hey how's it go it's your boy back at it
again with another original unique
hilarious idea that no one's done before
pics two pics as you can clearly tell
never done before funny and original
content hair wait up okay so if you for
some reason don't know what this is I
don't know what the [ __ ] how you ended
up here without knowing about it I mean
the verge posted about it okay
so everyone should know about it and the
verse can you please just link to the
goddamn thing cuz I can if you never
find it
all right you always hid it somewhere oh
there it is great basically this drawing
will become this person right hilarious
so what happens then if I remove her
eyes I don't know what I expected was
gonna happen but it happened and thus
Slenderman was born Jesus Christ
this is slowly turning me on I like it
how would this look oh wow how did they
make the line so [ __ ] thing god damn
this thing is terrifying
yes I get it now my god she's absolutely
beautiful finally I can make my dream
girl come true in this video game but if
we make the mouth just a little happier
just a tad bit a little happier oh my
gosh you got a snake Kai right yes yes
yes yes yes but what if her face what's
a penis
thank you everyone let's try it out
that is much better I like how the balls
someone made it in there I don't know
how finally finally my dream girl right
here on the Buddha Pi Channel marzia I
am sorry but I have found a more perfect
specimen I like to call her Jerry and he
loves me for who I am
Oh Jerry don't be so angry what did I do
I'm sorry I'm sorry Jerry
abort abort could this perhaps make you
happier Jerry Oh Jerry
related to the elephants I can tell I
can tell yes I am 12 by the way in case
you're wondering yes I am thank you very
much thank you for subscribing and
living in like on this video right now
yes I am drawing a dick on a woman's
face yes this is the pinnacle of comedy
you've just found it here on this
channel
congratulation it's never going to be
better than this let's laugh at some
more penises family friendly Felix haha
yes
family friendly Felix I mean I'm not
gonna lie I've been with worse women I'm
talking of course about your mama your
mama everybody your mama jokes haha ah I
have seen death and he stares but it
looks so cute it looks so sad what the
hell is this how I Disney oh my god
[ __ ] sexy this is sexy I finally
finally can create my perfect human ha
let's try and draw the most beautiful
specimen of all 10th May hey why not
just draw myself from real time how
about that ok alright
big-ass nose yes huh no upper lip but a
giant bottom lip yep that's it very
pointy jaw eyebrows that could face any
anime character Wow look at that I'm
goddamn perfect I have a feeling that
this is not gonna this is not gonna look
pretty let's watch what the [ __ ] is that
how the [ __ ] did that happen no no no no
no what the [ __ ] is No
kill it kill it man if old fan out of me
was this good boy I could only dream
okay here we go
now you just be me how do you go from
this to this
[ __ ] you picks two picks you don't know
[ __ ]
alright let's draw the second second
most beautiful specimen that's her name
Marsha
this is really my Monalisa but in the
future they won't be talking about Mona
Lisa they'll be talking about Marsha oh
my god
she's absolutely perfect okay let's
watch
oh my god let's try them out another one
okay all right let's actually maybe
maybe I could have made her a little bit
more prettier
okay well I don't see how this one can
fail at all so I mean I still hated it
you know what I mean oh yeah
this is mean finally I can fap to my own
porn hell yeah yeah wait wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute yeah boy boy
you're looking sexy girl or the perfect
Simon
the perfect way man that I would finally
a whamon I can respect I know what
you're thinking what about your dog
Pitts surely your dog must look at least
decent in this and then I agree 100%
because they seem to make everything
[ __ ] black in this game a racist game
everyone kind of looks cute I kind of
like my fan out of Edgar here thank you
God
this is why Darwin was wrong you still
believe in global warming well I have
solid evidence to prove against it what
the [ __ ] look at that thing it's
beautiful Wow finally now that I'm a
human you can treat me nice shut the
well it was bound to happen what about
Jack spit I see let's do the pretty
version of Jack it's a good thing that
I'm such a impeccably perfect artist I
get I get commissioned requests all the
[ __ ] time all the time people's like
hey I want to pay you because I love
love your art
how the [ __ ] did I make him more pretty
that was that possible I [ __ ] it
they all just get [ __ ] werewolves
well the [ __ ] that knows though why are
they old werewolves stop is it the
eyebrows for [ __ ] sake stop being
werewolves it's not that hard obviously
we have to draw the absolute most
beautiful specimen of all time Nick
prompted he's a goddamn perfect human
being and I want to see how he looks
like as an actual human add one of the
chins that he has let's add all the hair
that he has to hide that any fact that
he's [ __ ] huge
there we go Nick Crompton everyone oh my
[ __ ] god it looks just like him I did
it I finally did it
holy [ __ ] I knew I could do it if I just
put my mind to it you can do it if you
just put your mind to it and say [ __ ]
let's screw it Nick Crompton let me [ __ ]
you that's a freestyle song about my
love for you Nick why haven't you
returned my calls
emails text messages what are you I
thought you were gay what about what
about slippy would sleep you look at it
come on game don't yes yes that's my boy
are you looking good [ __ ] where how did
you go I'm sure he's fine what about my
Twitter avatar
[Music]
all right here we go what what I hope
you enjoyed this video leave a like all
my sister ficers out there I'll see you
tomorrow with another episode and as
always